you want this life go get it you want
this it's not common for you you got to
make that happen you can't be tough on
men anymore
that's somehow bad what are you supposed
to do sit down with your son and say
you're a victim of society don't work
too hard it's gonna what kind of
messaging is that to a young man so what
that man grows up and and what isn't fit
to take care of himself let alone a
family instead the guy listening to
Andrew Tate grows up that kid grows up
and says you know what it's my
responsibility to do these things and I
have to make sure that I can make it
happen and there's going to be some
bumps along the road it's my job to pick
myself up by my bootstrap so that I can
be that provider for my family that's
somehow bad now you see how twisted and
warped not only Society at large but
these men are that now these men are
saying that that's somehow bad because
they've been programmed so heavily
unbelievable stuff